hello reject nation it's greg alba here
i'm john so we're gonna talk about a
movie that should have been released in
january and might have gotten better
reception if it did but because they
came out in february it's a terrible
movie apparently yeah we're talking
about of course none other the
winchester winchester now last time we
did an official movie review and not the
call me by her name one word official
one was the post and so we said we're
gonna be reimplemented our reasons to
see list or to break our reviews down by
a reason to see and reasons not to see
bullet points and i want to start off
before going into that that we don't
think this movies as terrible as
everyone's making it out to be before
doing this review i saw it had a 12% on
Rotten Tomatoes granted it's not great
it's just it's got its moments
anyway let's hop into this list please
reason to see number one is jason
caloric one of the many Australian
actors playing an American and yeah
Jason Clarke who you know from playing
John Connor and he's one of those actors
that I think has the potential to become
a really huge actor right now he's one
of those like oh people know of Jason
Clarke but he's not talk caliber yet
especially I think even looking back on
the trailer and really remember even
seeing him that much in the trailer he's
in and I watched it this morning but I
just completely forgot about it until
the movie started I was like what Jason
Clarke yeah he's actually the real lead
of the movie Helen Mirren's more of the
supporting role like she's the main
character but the supporting characters
of all the intrigue centers yeah
and Jason Clarke plays this therapist
who is struggling from PTSD essentially
and he's also addicted to medication
basically he gets a sign on this mission
to go meet with Sarah Winchester with a
Winchester people created those guns the
Winchester rifles whatnot her to the
repeating Arms Company company is trying
to boot her out so they want him to
basically diagnosed her as clinically
insane or something unless
to lead and Jason Clarke's performance
in this film is a big part of why I
think this film is not terrible if he
sucked this movie I would easily agree
with everyone else because he's the one
who's primarily commanding the screen
for majority of this film he's one of
those characters were the first half of
the movie or majority of the movie that
I believe in goes that I do not believe
in anything I cannot see what studies
got his eyes but a lot of the time in
horror movies that trope can really
irritate the crap out of me he really
sells it everything about the way his
character is written and his portrayal
his subtlety is nuances he's a
multi-layered character he's a guy who
puts on a personality in a facade but
really has a lot of deep dark depression
yeah it didn't feel like this movie
needed him to be skeptical it felt like
a natural choice before that character
and you know the dude states it seemed
very early on as you pointed out and he
does a good job at driving that home and
he gives a very lived in performance
yeah considering the kind of movie this
is like he showed up to it yeah it's I
think he gives a great performance he
elevates the material there are times
when it's kind of beyond elevation but
there are also other times where he
elevates the material or really brings
it to life you know in an uneven movie
he shines kind of throughout reason to
see number two Helen Mirren sort of yeah
Helen Mirren is in this moment and for
part of it you people just kind of spend
time in foe dumping you about her life
and then she stands up and she's like hi
I'm spooky and then she leaves again it
was weird about the characters Helen
Mirren makes the character interesting
yeah I feel like the writing did lack on
making her character that much more
interesting it took a while for that
character to start feeling like they
were actually giving her material
totally yeah I feel like the idea of
putting Helen Mirren on the reasons to
see section of this video is more
because of the intrigue of wanting to
see Helen Mirren in a horror movie
and playing you know like an Oda is a
good role in in terms of subject yeah
I've heard of plays a historic place
it's real as a real person yeah there's
weight to this she does elevate the film
a little bit here and there it's really
because the writing doesn't really give
her much to do rather than cliche woman
who's in touch with spirits and demons
you know I feel like a lease from
insidious is a much more intriguing
character yeah and that's a complaint in
terms of the scripting but in terms of
just her performance I thought every
scene she showed up for she brought
something to again kind of like Jason
Clark even if it wasn't supporting her
she was still supporting it yeah and
also Jason Clark and Helen Mirren they
work very well together they do in fact
some of the best moments in this movie
are just scenes were there sitting down
and talking and the characters are
actually developing yeah you know and
that goes for some of the supporting
cast too I mean there are some good
smaller performances especially from
Sarah snook who plays the Sarah's niece
and she's an actress I've seen a couple
of the Spirit Brothers movies she always
does a terrific job and especially again
in a movie like this she brings a good
amount of weight to a character that
could have just been bland pretty much
the whole cast is pretty solid in this
film even like the little roles the
supporting roles there they're all very
good in this film it's something you
can't discredit this movie on is that
the acting in it is really good and
everyone showed up nobody just collected
the paycheck oh yes I didn't feel like
reason to see number three the finale
we're gonna be hopping into our reasons
not to see in a second year yeah but I
would say that finale was surprisingly
intense yeah I'll admit that the first
two-thirds of this film all the horror
movie stuff wasn't that scary to me
there was an occasional good creep
moment there was an occasional good jump
scare moment here there but the finale
actually had a good like 10 to 15
minutes that was when actually kind of
pretty scared right yeah when the real
climax of the movie started yeah it took
me by surprise I was like oh oh this
movie seems like it's heating up toward
the end now that whole finale sequence
grabbed me so much more it felt like the
third act of a different movies sort of
every element came together finally to
make something that I was totally pulled
in
yeah and also there's some twists and
reveals there some of the twists and
reveals - I actually it didn't dawn on
me till I was going to bed what you were
doing in the theater when because the
twist has some stuff that in it that's
clever there's some stuff there we're
like that's a little silly overall that
mean the twist and reveal part I wasn't
expecting that to be in this movie I
thought it would just be like
information we learned there were stuff
there like oh there was some
foreshadowing that they were doing that
was cleverly handled so I'm a bit not
was just a little cheesy yeah but
there's other elements to it that
without we're good and I thought overall
the character arc was predictable but
good yeah and I mean that's the point in
the movie were like it's shot the best
it's the most intense it's hairiest and
it also borrows from the sort of
spiritual mythology like there's some
actual cathartic character moments and
this whole thing about why the spirits
are there in the connection to the house
like that kind of makes the finale have
a good amount of weight that's beyond
just scares you know there's an actual
kind of a meaning to it yeah and it does
make the rest of the movie kind of worth
it to me that's been what's our reasons
not to see people reasons not to see
lacklustre writing and cliche haunted
house tropes so the first two-thirds of
this film like everything before the
finale is intermittent very specific
ways what I found really weird about
this experience is it's not like a tone
in this movie spirit brothers tend to
steer away from that it's not exactly a
fun one either there's a weird
Livelihood tone it's a period piece film
it reminded me of from hell for some
reason yeah it's more long that tone I
think because what was weird to me about
it is there was okay first off there's
some pretty bad expositional dialogue in
here so much like in the film the first
moment that's about to kick the plot off
in catalyst five-minute scene where
somebody just gives you a entire
biography of Sarah Winnie you could
justify it like well he has to at the
same time it doesn't feel that way and I
think
there's a pretty good amount of moments
I said it right in the moves done the
spirit brothers to me are more concept
people than script people and I and
Johnny he said I think they could use a
punch up writer they actually this was
written by somebody else and they did
some rewrites on it I think it's really
by a guy who's only done like one or two
other small things they were trying to
get information okay well they need a
different problem there is yeah it's
kind of uneven in the sense that some of
the character scenes are pretty good and
that others are just here's some a
composition and we'll moving right along
there are a lot of shameless jump scares
although on the flip side of that
usually they're technically effective
yeah they're just not always more than a
jump scare I know the cool thing to do
on especially on the Internet is bash
jump scares like the second there's a
jump scare to movie a lot of people are
like ding hate the movie yeah I don't
feel that way about jump scares not even
in this movie like I felt like they made
the sense just as much as they would
have been an insidious move there was a
couple of jump scares that really got me
that were truly clever in my opinion I
think they tease it in the trailer
though which sucks with the mayor
sequence yeah they do show the trailer
thinks oh I forgot all the show part but
when I saw that in the theaters there's
more to it things they show in the
trailer and it really did get me there's
a couple of moments that are leading
into the finale that really got me to
the horror movie elements and the period
drama elements don't coalesce really
until the end however I do think that
the spirit brothers have a certain grip
on every tone and aggressive jump scares
that occasionally do work in this movie
they just don't always blend together
well the weird part about it is when it
wasn't being a horror movie is when I
was most intrigued by what was going oh
yeah it kind of felt like what they
could have done is dial back a lot of
the cliche predictable tropes that they
would sprinkle in randomly through the
first and second act don't worry so much
about the conjurer
like yeah I felt like there was
reminders of oh yeah it's a horror movie
it's a period when they because they
could have had to be a build-up movie to
the finale and the finale would have
been that much more intense if there
wasn't these silly jump-scare moments
and cliche horror movie tropes that kept
cranly me throwin because whenever it
wasn't doing that that's when I was most
intrigued by the film when there were a
character scenes or intense sequences
there's intense sequences that happen
with Sarah Snooks Sun in the film I
don't want to give it away because they
don't show it in a trailer but there was
a couple of moments there that I thought
were intense and weren't played as
jump-scare moments whatever it wasn't
being horror movie that I was most
intrigued so that was the weird part of
the experience because when it was
horror movie
I wasn't liking those scenes they just
didn't have as much flavor and as much
like what makes this movie unique I
guess is a lot of the dramatic stuff
partly because you do have a rich
history to draw from if this was my
movie I would have approached this like
the others or something like that yeah I
think they utilize the house pretty well
it's like it's well captured and stuff
there are times especially throughout
those first two-thirds where you're like
I'm reminded of many other horror movies
yeah I feel like this could have been
longer a little bit you know it's like a
solid hour and a half because of that it
feels like kind of a haunted you know
just real standard honey that's why I
was saying that they could have dialed
back some of the horror movie trope
stuff and then made it a build up movie
to the finale which I thought would have
been way more effective yeah I would
agree with that all right well yeah I
mean would I say this movies is awful as
a 12 percent or however rating everyone
else is making it out to be I wouldn't
because I truly think that in our
reasons to see there are there are stuff
here to appreciate that does elevate it
from that yeah there's good work in this
movie is just that there are a lot of
better our coalescent haunted house
movie let's say it's okay
yeah it's alright it's alright it's
charms you know and the fact that it
came together at the end and the
climax is actually kind of whole you
know that that elevated like a half
story yeah alright guys well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification melih get notified every
time one of our videos is up you can
check out our patreon a lot of exclusive
videos over there a lot of exclusive
perks as well and Dallin and follow us
on the stardust posting regularly on
there Papes